NARRATOR: It is a moment of
great excitement on Oak Island.
Rick Lagina and
Gary Drayton welcome
representatives from
Brycon Construction
and Irving Equipment Ltd.
They have come to make the final
preparations for what promises
to be the most ambitious
and technologically advanced
operation ever attempted--
Mike, how are you doing?
NARRATOR: --in the 223 year
long history of the Oak
Island Treasure Hunt--
the installation of a
25-foot deep metal coffer
dam off the coast
of Smith's Cove.
When completed,
the encircled area
will be drained and then
excavated in an effort
to find the elusive
flood tunnels,
and perhaps a direct entrance
to the Oak Island Money Pit.
But before construction of
the coffer dam can begin,
a new access road and
platform must be laid out
to allow for the
massive equipment,
including a 300-ton
crane, to be transported
down to the beach area.
That crane is the
biggest item that
will have to be moved down.
And then, of course, it
will have to track out.
So we have to seriously
reconfigure the path
from 10X down to Smith's Cove.
And by serious, I
mean quite serious.
Once this process gets all done,
what's your timing look like?
We're thinking it's
probably a week and a half.
Aside from that, I think you
guys got your marching orders.
And anything we can
do, you let us know.
Fair enough?
- Yep.
That's no problem.
All right, gentlemen.
Good luck.
NARRATOR: With the new road
to the beach completed,
brothers Rick and Marty
Lagina are finally
ready to break ground on
this summer's most ambitious
and most eagerly
anticipated project,
the excavation of Smith's Cove.
Today, the team from
Irving Equipment Ltd.
has begun delivering the
heavy machines and equipment
that will be needed
in order to construct
a massive steel coffer dam.
[truck horn]
They're here.
Well, here we go.
Pretty remarkable,
isn't it David?
NARRATOR: Over
the next few days,
the team will assemble a 300-ton
crane at the Money Pit area
before it can be staged on the
nearby beach, where some 2,200
tons of earth have
been moved to build
a perfectly flat work surface.
And in a couple of days,
that will be put together.
Yep.
And roughly two,
three weeks from now,
we'll be down at target depth.
It's cool.
Just think how long
it took your father.
We didn't have
the technology then.
Exactly.
NARRATOR: Once the
crane is in place,
construction can finally
begin on the nearly 525-foot
long watertight barrier.
When it is completed, the
ocean water will be drained out
and then the entire area,
nearly 12,000 square feet,
will be excavated.
This will allow the
team to uncover not only
important artifacts, such
as the mysterious lead cross
discovered at Smith's
Cove last year,
but also possible evidence of
an ancient flood tunnel system.
Because of the
find of the cross,
we have to do a
very disciplined,
archaeologically-driven dig
in order to see if there
are other similar artifacts.
We've always thought that
there may be a treasure trove
of information in Smith's Cove.
At the end of this
exercise, we're
going to know more
about Smith's Cove
than has ever been known before.
It's a big operation.
It's scary in a sense.
It's daunting and it's exciting.
There's a story here--
Yep.
--and it's
constantly unraveling.
Yeah.
For me, the quest
is really to find out
what happened here long ago.
And I hope that there's
answers down there.
I do too.